virtual reality vr ist das große ding
und vielleicht einmal teil unseres
lebens riffs google karte oder jetzt das
argument reality kids von apple will nur
der erste schritt vielleicht werden
schon bald realität und virtuelle
realität zusammenwachsen
die unterhaltungsindustrie macht vor in
welche richtung die reise in die
virtuelle welt gäbe was alles möglich
ist eine realität die nur virtuell
existiert die man aber erfährt und
erfüllt wie die wirklichkeit fliegen
wie ein vogel kino mit allen sinnen
erleben oder als astronaut durch das all
4 beeindruckende beispiele für wie a
bekommt ihr jetzt in kriegszeiten
fiction und am ende und noch ein
wirklich klappe geschenk also bleibt
dran herzlich willkommen
not geht also mit dem top 4 der
virtuellen realität in der
unterhaltungsindustrie und meine
empfehlung wenn ihr die chance gehabt
unbedingt ausprobieren und zwar erleben
wie unsere zukunft aussehen könnte und
hier wird sie platz vier wie ama
kinofilme groß virtual reality gilt als
die große hoffnung der kinoindustrie
niederländische unternehmen fernholz
media zeigt warum bei den sogenannten
pop up kinos werden ein fest
installierter kinosaal mit leinwand
nicht mehr gebraucht die kinozuschauer
sitzen mit dia brille und kopfhörer
ausgestattet in bequemen drehstuhl so
kann jeder für sich selbst entscheiden
was er schreibt einen horror film in dem
ein krankenpfleger durch eine einsame
irrenanstalt zum beispiel oder aber man
begleitet ein flüchtlingsmädchen auf
ihrem alltag in einem flüchtlingscamp
dpa holt die milder solar und echt an
einen heran dass manche kinobesucher es
tatsächlich kaum aushalten
die brille auf dem kopf zu behalten
einen kleinen nachteil hat dass die akin
und dennoch dieses gefühl von
gemeinschaft sich zusammen einen film
anschauen
das geht verloren denn jeder ist
wortwörtlich im seiner seinem eigenen
film
was zudem 2016 gibt es das erste kino
europa finale samt berlin hat
nachgezogen und die idee hat zukunft ist
mir zum beispiel hat bereits 60
millionen us-dollar in die technik
investiert
platz drei achterbahnfahren gewinnt mit
wa im europapark rust in der nähe von
freiburg kann man virtual reality
kombiniert mit einer achterbahnfahrt
erlebt die ganz mutigen achterbahn
begeisterten ziehen vor fahrtbeginn ein
kabelloses headset auf stadt durch die
gewöhnliche modellierter edelstein -
sofern reitet man so auf drachen durch
die luft und erlebt ganz andere
abenteuer durch einen selber am rates
zugeführt der jeweilige filmausschnitt
mit der fahrstrecke synchronisiert
geplante weitere szenarien der solche
freizeitpark ist keine seltenheit
in einem englischen vergnügungspark
kann man mittlerweile mit bis zu 75 km
pro stunde ins all reisen zunächst geht
es zur virtuellen raketenabschussrampe
von wo die intergalaktische reisebeginn
die strecke führt die besucher dann am
orionnebel durch wurmlöcher vorbei in
bisher und
die galaxien platz zwei frei wie ein
vogel mit dem flugsimulator berkeley ein
traum der menschen seit jeher fliegen
wie ein vogel
der flugsimulator berkeley des schweizer
startups song max lässer realität
werden zumindest fast euch links legt
man sich auf eine art zahnarztstuhl und
setzt sich eine opfers via brille und
einem kopfhörer auf und schon gleitet
man also rotmilan über städte wie new
york das besondere hierbei man steuert
nicht einfach eine maschine sondern
fliegt selbst mit den eigenen händen
beziehungsweise flügeln steuert man
findet man sie an steuert der
flugsimulator nach rechts oder links in
die kurve sollten beispielsweise nach
unten fühlte sich tatsächlich wieder
sind klug an
ein ventilator sorgt für den gegenwind
der umso stärker ist die schneller man
fliegt die entwickler aus der schweiz
binden
bei dieser idee aber noch mehr würde
ein sogar gerüche lassen sich einmal
das ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend weil
es sich einfach sehr realistisch
anfühlt sagen zumindest die testperson
der berkeley kann man tatsächlich
kaufen wir ein preis ist vergleichbar
mit dem eines mittelklasse war
platz ein abenteuer in einem wm-spiel
platz im amerikanischen utah letzter tag
bereut besucher in verlassenen tempeln
oder düsteren labors indiana jones
spiel virtuelle realität wird mit wind-
wasser- und wänden verbunden und zwar
auf einem 30.000 quadratmeter großen
jahr später weitere sind weltweit in
planung ausgestattet mit media brille
kopfhörer und gesten scanner sowie
einem laptop auf dem rücken begeben
sich die besucher in einen endlosen raum
mitten im dschungel versteckt sich hier
ein tempel die steinwände um einen
herum kann man anfassen
an der wand hängen feuer fackeln und
irgendwo brennt ein feuer
die wärme die die besucher spuren
spricht dafür dass das feuer wirklich
brennt plötzlich erschüttert ein
virtuelles erdbeben die landschaft um
einen herum ein rumpelnde aufzug des
tempels expedition bringt einen in
sicherheit
die macher haben so manche tricks auf
lager hat damit die virtuelle welt so
gut mit der physischen abonniert eine
gebogene wand vermittelt den besuchern
das gefühl immer nur geradeaus zu gehen
dabei werden die möglichkeit die ganze
zeit im kreis geführt der wasserfall
wird durch ventilatoren und spritzdüsen
betrieben der rumba aufzug
nur ein kleines fest dass von motoren
betrieben und gerüttelt wird so
beeindruckend war virtuelle realität
wohl noch nie vielen dank an technology
review in zusammenarbeit mit der
redaktion dieser wirklich tollen salz
dürfte dieses video entstanden und
exklusiv wird sich zum zuschauer habe
jetzt ein kleines geschenk
ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis
wenn ihr auf diesen link legt es lohnt
sich kann ich nur sagen und der hier
geht es weiter mit künstliche
intelligenz die größte gefahr für die
menschheit klick drauf wenn es euch
interessiert und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt